today on the show man it's all Star Wars
movie you haven't even heard about yet
what and Creed yes max of trailers
including fantastic what is it fantastic
bestiality sounds so hot all that and so
much more on this episode of fat man our
Batman
Thank You Harry welcome back man this is
the what are we calling it the Christmas
Eve edition it is a fat man I'm Batman
I'm Kevin Smith mark Barnard yeah and
what is still Star Wars month year this
time the release of Star Wars feels like
my wife when she's like it's my birthday
month pretty much just NX is it same
thing man they need to do this every
year I'm into it like like you know you
saw my review last week and stuff but
they need to have they should just give
Christmas to Star Wars yeah except that
there's shifting I think episode 8 is
gonna be May again yeah I think they
only did December because they needed
more time to make it but now that
they've got another year and a half to
do they're gonna go back to the may
schedule see I heard that they did
December because of the holiday
multiplier like if you look at the
records avatars the highest-grossing
film of all time still
released around the holidays guys the
number 2 movie was Titanic released
around the holidays neither um summer
movies my quick correct so I think
certainly with the Lord of the Rings
diseases making money in the winter time
and all right a movie so if I think if I
remember correctly I think it was a
strategic first-order type effort to be
like mmm this if we're gonna open with a
bang
why compete like we can have all of
winter and and what rules about that is
you got this thing called the holiday
multiplier at the box office right which
we're seeing in full effect right now
for example everyone's aw I mean these
cats they look three years out at a
[ __ ] calendar and these are these are
the people that make movies do not like
is the person who looks at the calendar
three years out and goes okay this
Monday Tuesday if we open on this Friday
this Monday Tuesday and Wednesday and
Thursday till Christmas every one of
these days is a Friday at the box office
right Christmas happens we're gonna rake
in even more money because family this
is a [ __ ] family film if ever there
was one and then all the way through
January they're gonna continue to earn
so if you were gonna go for that times
law
you know the the highest-grossing film
of all time which as we've seen after
this opening weekend it's got a good
shot at there in spitting distance like
you know there are a lot of pieces and
all these peopie had a piece on Forbes
two months ago gone money holy [ __ ]
fired at yeah so sorry Forbes yeah
so at the end of the day you know this
movie might just get there I didn't
totally will and it based on quality
alone like you know it's it's it's like
a milkshake of a movie mmm where you're
like oh man I'd have if somebody was
like you on milkshake like meaning like
hey you want to see force awakens again
do you like pizza sure one more pizza
why not actly now I saw some cats online
get all shitty about like how come you
like this movie it's just a repeat of
[ __ ] Star Wars I'm like well it is a
sequel so that was bound to happen some
elements of the other movies might be a
play here but then even people are come
on B for beta stars I can't disagree
like yeah there are big elements you
know Death Star 3 is kind of like the
Empire of the first order whoever makes
another Death Star yeah I mean it's not
like there's your campaign right there
if you're the other guy the Republic
candidate and stuff and the [ __ ]
first-order candidate is like you know
what's gonna [ __ ] take care [ __ ]
around here we're going to build a giant
gun in a panic but this one's gonna be
better I swear yeah we had a 10 year old
look at the plans to make sure there
weren't giant [ __ ] holes you could
deposit torpedoes into that city though
honestly like suddenly people got shitty
but though come on I'm like yeah look
Lucas himself did another Death Star ooh
the master himself and that's another
interesting thing you're seeing online
for the last 10 years they've been
banded Lucas over and just like here's
your Jar Jar right and crazy nuts going
after him I was reading deadline is week
when they read the box office reports
and man you wanna you know when you
the comments don't mean of that world Oh
God everyone's erudite everybody knows
how Hollywood should be running [ __ ]
like that but it's crazy how many people
like you know people like I like this
movie but how all the sudden people are
like well Lucas was a visionary and and
then they start making like the prequels
okay to going like look you may not like
Jar Jar but at least he expanded his
universe whereas this movie feels like
fanservice I'm glad it's fanservice man
like this is the this is the age of the
fan sir of the fan film like where
they'll give a bunch of money to
somebody who loves that thing more than
the person maybe created it I'll tell
you right now like that doesn't offend
me in the least we've seen two prime
examples of that in this season JJ
Abrams Star Wars Force awakens Ryan
Coogler Creed yeah I mean like here's
the thing ultimate fan film I feel like
stylin I'm sorry I don't want people
shut up mark no dick before people go
are you [ __ ] dismiss a piece of [ __ ] I
don't mean that it's like clear these
are fan films it's crazy like these
these are two cats had no connection to
the source material other than I love it
more than I love my own life and we're
eventually given the keys to the kingdom
and created really great additions to
those franchises I feel like I've
completely revived both of them I feel
like the key to it to do in a Star Wars
movie is to realize that it's not about
you is to get out of the way and when
Lucas made the first one like yes out of
whole cloth invented the the awesome for
the other two movies for Empire and Jedi
he kind of got out of the way wasn't
about him it was let me take a look tell
a good story let me give these other
directors let me make a thing when he
comes back for the prequels they become
about him had become about who he is and
I love trade Federation's and I love
negotiations and blockades and [ __ ] like
that
JJ realized it's not about me I need to
get out of the way and yes in a large
part remake that first movie and I'm
fine with that
like I'm fine with where I desert planet
and the plans are droid and there's a
princess maybe who gets kidnapped on a
thing that we got to go rescue and
there's a trench run and were blown up
another Death Star
all right that's cool I like all those
things why not give me more of those
things exactly why
that wrong why is it like there some
cats and believe me it's minor like the
it seems like the whole the Internet is
on his side largely totally even like
the people you know are normally kind of
negative or like look I liked it yeah
hardcore negative people that I can't do
it can you are can you find problems
with that movie you can find problems
with any movie but ultimately it's
harder to make you feel like that's what
you go to the movies for and myself you
know I mean that's it was exactly what I
wanted that's the thing and now I
understand the Lucas quote remember what
he was just like the fans are gonna love
this yes yeah it's not the movie I would
have made but the fans are gonna love it
because he didn't matter he didn't know
how to get out of its way work that you
know like I get it he's like look I
wasn't interested in making a fan film
he's gone I didn't ever make a fan film
a Star Wars for me and this is what I
wanted to do and other people really
liked it and then we expanded the world
not a lot other people direct and stuff
like that but when I came back to direct
years later I come back with the same
methods by which I made American
Graffiti thx 1-1 3-8 and Star Wars which
is like nothing about an audience he
told us every time it's like I haven't
looked at the internet a long time I
don't know what people want or care
about the 400-acre village I built for
myself I never leave
so this is a man who did get his own
planet mm-hmm by just going like wow I'm
gonna tell the story I want to tell ya
so he went back to tell stories okay
sounds like a story of a guy do I need
my own fire department I think I do
this like it's his so you do with it
what he wants but the thing was
everybody feels like oh my god Star Wars
is mine because I saw it with my dad you
know this time in my life and I was a
super fan had all the toys and they're
right - nobody's wrong you know and we
got and everybody now everybody's
getting what they wanted like George
Lucas got to make exact movies he wanted
making stuff and they still exist
they're not going anywhere by the way
they did not fail none of them did no I
mean like people who could be like [ __ ]
Georgia those movies made billions of
dollars yeah so if they were successful
their sums were my finger in the top ten
right I think well yeah I mean there's
the first three yeah so well the first
trilogy but I think one of the prequel
coming sister so it's like obviously he
did what he wanted to do and I was happy
with the VEX look how happy he is he
wants to be the master and now fans get
what they want where you know and he
sold it to Disney it sound like yeah
doesn't he wrestle it away from the
night like that like Finn NuStar was as
Finn was ripped away from his parents
Star Wars was not ripped away from
George Lucas he sold it to Disney and
Disney was like how do we make four
billion dollars back ooh let's make a
movie just like the first movie that
everybody loves a lot and makes yes yes
forbid not be for being in terms of like
it's a carbon copy of the movie but just
all what are the elements what was the
magic
what's the patron it's no formula but
like what did y'all love about so that's
JJ's thing JJ's things moments like let
me give you this moment that will be the
thing that you love the most and when
Ray gets that [ __ ] lightsaber it's
the it's one of my favorite moments of
the year I saw some some guy reviewed it
I forget where it was and he was saying
I want to say was like New Yorker and he
was saying like you know every moment
feels designed to have an applause sign
behind it but I'm like yeah and that's
pleasing movie yeah like I wanted to
like let's get on this ship boom all
right let's take the junker it's the
Falcon I wanted that I wanted those who
I wanted to be like you know the door
comes up I wanted to be in a theater
that applauded and stuff like that so I
got what I wanted totally I think a lot
of people did I think that I'm loving
the thing that I love the most about
this is I'm looking at Twitter and I'm
looking at all these women that I follow
on Twitter who were like now I feel like
I'm a part of this you know like like
Ray is the thing I've always wanted I
didn't want to be a princess I wanted to
be a smuggler I wanted to be smart I
wanted a lightsaber
my wife said did I sat there with my
wife and my wife was just like I've been
waiting 30 years for this yeah you know
she's like she she's like you don't get
it I had I had Princess Leia in my youth
that's all I had a woman with a gun the
only woman in that whole movie like kind
of with a gun and she's like to see
what's gonna watch the finale yeah
they're just like to go into the big
fight it looks like this come here go to
watch shot yeah this is this is [ __ ]
Star Wars Princess Leia in Star Wars hmm
man right there okay fly boy bad Emma
but they found a farm boy I guess it's
better than me somehow so today I'm
gonna sit here look work I've only got
like 10 years in the Senate
our shooting stormtroopers like two
hours ago the [ __ ] neck who else goes
up against Vader and walks away me way I
do that did you see the giant black ball
he brought stab me with and tell the
truth what else you got hey what's going
on it would a real action set yeah this
time around she gets the lightsaber it
gets to be like and take them on I saw
some [ __ ] get real upset I lied about
that too dude you're like look dude I'm
as geeky as they get you know what I'm
saying but [ __ ] like this cut makes me
scared for Humanity some guy going like
[ __ ] that Rey could be kylo Ren if
he's as trained in the Jedi arts as
they're saying and then goes on to write
a dissertation about how she you know
there is [ __ ] love me dude I do
I [ __ ] love to Adam driver in this
movie I would watch more movies about
kylo Ren they're gonna got even if they
were like hey we're gonna get rid of Chu
it'd be like alright more kylo Ren I
liked it yeah I liked you in quite a bit
too any [ __ ] so now next movie is
like Death Wish with you here's here's
the thing that I miss the most from this
movie that I wanted more than I than
anything
didn't get I wanted the funeral scene I
wanted I wanted they ended a movie like
that we didn't Revenge of the Sith end
with like Oh remember [ __ ] what the
first movie ended with a big parade mm
and then the last movie ends with a big
[ __ ] funeral like that was the last
thing he's on Star Wars except for you
know the kid on the plume the kid on the
planet but like I wanted I wanted the
scene where Leia has to eulogize home
you know and then tell me what he meant
to her what he means to the fans like do
that thing where she tells me what I'm
supposed to feel and I'm crying so you
wanted the burial we're gonna pick up
the first one with a funeral scene
because that's how you start a
blockbuster
we're rebooting the franchise you don't
want to send people home on a down no
we're gonna celebrate his death in the
or at the very least I wanted like
Chewie to hug
Leia like they both lost the most
important person they've ever known they
had the pre moment mmm literally it's
like chewy is walking off the ship and
Leia walks right past him and goes to
this girl I've never met before she
needs a hug I was not that was did take
me out of movie one iota well she
doesn't I believe the title of the movie
mark was the force awakens so to me it
felt like in that frame [ __ ] for so
many kids it was a little bit I was like
well here's the title in action and so I
didn't it didn't bother me that she
fought well I think she was fluid like
she kept doing this [ __ ] a lot of stab
yeah like which is a weirdest move I've
never do that I feel like my grandma
duck you'd probably push
right through me probably but that I'm
like I'm I'm figuring I'm gonna die
anyway [ __ ] like to tell you
man there's a scene in Return of the
Jedi
there's always baffled me it was
probably one of the reasons when I talk
about Star Wars my movies
Cena returned the Jedi with Luke
Skywalker sitting there
the Emperor's in the big chair and he's
like grab your weapon I could be down
Luke's looking at and starts jiggling
Darth Vader's right there and [ __ ] and
all he has to do is and kill the Emperor
and he sucks and injures and makes the
move in force grabs him and then comes
right at the Emperor's face of course
Darth Vader much faster blow out the
show whole [ __ ] thing changes if he
does all he does is grabs it zoom it
does this [ __ ] as it goes on turns
around and Darth Vader
wouldn't even know what hit him like who
lose the arm the chair and they try just
like [ __ ] turn on when it's honest
honest little armrest they're just a
true Jedi wouldn't even have to grab the
mic let's hear what he had to say yeah
hella Star Wars ladies and gentlemen of
Jason Kidd hi alright gonna give him a
single no no you wait there
how awesome he's like you've been in the
movie this is 20 or 22 years dude I'm
like give me a single I feel like I'll
run to the camera sit over there alright
so down the barrel that camera being his
on charge off a little bit there you go
not that now you don't want to see me
give yourself some stature yeah well
people being like I listen to this farm
over
down the barrel you tell them what you
chuck what you thought you tell me what
you thought of course awaken
wait what's first Wiggins no it's a it's
a was I mean it it made me cry made me
tear up there's a little little even the
little things silly a little comment
they may I mean I comment but he han
Solo says
yes I guess aim spray Han Solo says is
there a trash compactor you like just
that I mean there's a lot more than I
like yeah it was fantastic
I did no I didn't sorry but my buddy did
yes no I can if I have the Death Star I
didn't have anything I had like
cardboard boxes very great though right
like you put little holes in them little
little while yarn and you can have them
slide down and down [ __ ] that part
you're looking at a boy here a poor boy
who had to play Star Wars with like
potatoes salt shakers it was a toothpick
where's the lightsaber never saw a
sadder lightsaber fight than when a
pepper shaker goes against a carrot and
they're talking about before but the
movie was great honestly it it was right
from when the the scroll up
it made me tingle it gave me some you
know I would went and watched her with
the wife and well I don't know I was
hoping because I was there was a blanket
involved and I was trying to but anyway
but yeah I know it was she really does
yeah the I pick theater man and had the
reclining seats and you're like by
there's two seats by themselves a little
table you got to order soft pretzels
Pizza all of its broth used to get eat I
was like maybe tingle like Julia Child
it was yeah it was the combination now
but again the movie it was good again
for me
it was it seemed it was pretty long and
I feel like if I can stay awake and not
go run to the bathroom then I know I
enjoy the movie it's a weird little
judge I do know because I can't leave
because I'm like I can't miss anything
which I really dug but I guess maybe I
did like I did like Captain America's
well but yeah but start again Captain
America was fun Star Wars made me tingle
it's too different it's like having a
tingly butt or an erection Star Wars
erection thanks I had to I'm sorry but
anyway I'm glad I got to come on here
it's my first shot here on fat when I'm
Batman but as you can see as I'm talking
why I'm not never brought on as a guest
first
exactly exactly thank you everyone
the force if we'd met years ago marking
silently tremor in the force yeah
Creed's real quick I haven't seen we
talked about in the show you've seen it
I hadn't seen it you sold me out
all the tears man oh my lord what an
emotional what emotional film it was I
loved it and again like hats off to JJ
and to Ryan Coogler because that's the
kind of movie I want to see man yeah I
want to see like I've seen Sylvester
Stallone's rocky a few times like what
he did with his character he created he
can do anything less with his stuff but
it was awesome seeing somebody else be
like me put through this yeah prison and
that way he shined yeah and then still
hit every one of the beats you need out
of a rocky movie like there's still the
training montage there's still the fight
that he loses there's still the girl
that he's trying to romance and doesn't
quite know what to do with there's still
the big [ __ ] fight and it still works
everything still work I mean you want to
sound like people
like oh he just there's a lot of stuff
towards like the first Star Wars in the
force awakens just like Rocky III and
that's the reason we all go like
especially the first one when he's very
much what he's wooing Adrian he's like
standing outside the door like trying to
get her to come out they're the same
scenes in this movie where he's trying
to get what's her face
Tessa Tessa Thompson is the actress here
why people yeah yeah she's good she's
really good actors yeah I liked her in
that movie I liked her in this and I
liked her storylines
like with yeah the idea that she's a
musician who at some point will lose her
hearing come on and so everything for
her is just a race to get her work done
so she's like I'm gonna do what I love
and so I can't do any more yeah it's
kind of a metaphor for life yes she was
wonderful he was wonderful I mean look
like [ __ ] crazy
when Den's got in shape to do the
hurricane somebody said you should do an
action movie right after this cuz you're
45 years old and you will never look
like this again it's almost not possible
for a man of this age to keep looking
like this 60 years old he's the baddest
uncle you've ever had Mike was Michael B
Jordan Michael B George Michael B Jordan
did I thought I captured her he didn't
capture Apollo Creed was the actor's
name hello Carl Weathers Carl Weathers
he didn't do it Carl Weathers type of
performance it wasn't like doing it but
it captured the essence of the boxing
from boxing film goes way back even
before Rocky and they were making
black-and-white so yeah like rec room
for a heavyweight like it's because like
one person gets in a ring and you know
it's all about you and I mean
termination to get beyond there's
there's the motto a motto of it there's
the like all I have to do is beat this
guy up and I can win but there's any got
a third act instantly absolutely like
you know where you're going there's a
fight but I think it's it's a class
thing you know there's there's a sense
of I have nothing like I'm poor I'm
broke I have no opportunity unless I do
this thing which is dangerous and Amy
but he can do it all it takes is
commitment and and especially with Rakhi
not even talent
we're just heart like you have to want
it it's true like when you think about
when we were kids people not me but
healthier kids were like I'm Rocky I was
laying on my side going I'm Java a lot
of cats wanted to be like Rocky because
it was like you can even even Stevens
come from nowhere and rise mm-hmm
do you think the modern-day equivalent
is Batman like seriously most kids love
Batman and it is also an achievable
attainable goal not really but excel
except that a superpower is vast wealth
yeah they tell us in America we could
write but like there is the thing about
boxing where the the and it goes in
phases where there were the black boxers
and then the poor white boxes and then
the poor Hispanic boxers like it was
just it was a thing where the best
boxers were always the people who ended
the worst socially and so rocky in the
70s like plants are closing down like
people are out of work it's the it's the
sort of second boomlet of a depression
it's like I just want to and what the
sense I can rise and I can rise with my
fists and that how can then how come is
Creed entering or coming out at the same
type of time like why I mean just like
this movies entertaining on its own
merit but also leaning on a legacy it's
leaning on a legacy for sure but it's
also coming into work so that you don't
have seen Rocky know I've seen with
people who have no idea what Rocky is
like this is pretty good yeah Jays wife
she hadn't seen any of the Rockies and
she was really good but if we've seen
people are gonna start calling this the
all [ __ ] [ __ ] show all we ever do is
like my watch this [ __ ] I cried I cried
at this I can't help it man that move is
incredibly emotional cried during a
fight scene mmm jaren spoilers if you
haven't seen it go [ __ ] see it it's
so worth seeing Creed like you buy and
it gets [ __ ] knocked to the canvas
and there they do to knock to the canvas
Shawn's in this movie where it's almost
like they just [ __ ] like the camera
fall with the actor and you feel mmm the
head of like Jesus I never been knocked
boxing ring any interesting about I was
like that's close enough you've done all
the crap but he goes down and you know
account amount and stuff and in his head
he's seeing like everybody to girl
it's a shot his mom his adoptive mom
then he sees rocky as well and then they
cut this is so beautiful and then they
cut to like a shot of Apollo Creed in
the ring grainy footage from Rocky yeah
and he [ __ ] cops of a team and even
though the announcer is just like hey
just come back from the dead
oh you're like that's incredibly moving
right there he couldn't find the
strength to get up and all the even like
you know his surrogate dad rock and
stuff well got him up is the man he
never met legacy the idea of like this
name this man I can earn my place and
I'm gonna try to do this archive of the
biggest [ __ ] moment for me before the
last moment was when he's in the corner
and he's like you have to do is I'm
gonna call this fight and he's like no I
have to show him I'm not a mistake
come on forget it come on and I was like
that's why so it stands up and then the
[ __ ] music they think they'd held off
on that bill conti theme for the entire
movie until the 10th round and then it's
and then you realize judiciously yes
they waited to use it until a moment
that's gonna impact my exhaust ports man
oh they were [ __ ] credibly well done
give that man every movie to direct and
we were talking about a show that black
panther [ __ ] that every movie all of
giving them star was really although I
will I'll be the first to lead the
charge that I think JJ should direct the
whole trilogy mmm-hmm I thought he did
kill a job the first one I mean I know
they've already been keeping up with
those movies not [ __ ] our College
forever over
or Roger us is what I love I loved
looper but he'll like he did a killer
job it's crazy but that's what they did
with the first one beeping and and warm
meal the first one JJ JJ gets to be the
Lucas he gets to be the sort of
Godfather who oversees all of this stuff
yeah yeah that's true but I mean don't
you wanna be the JJ but here's the movie
like you know I understand they got
schedules people working on things but
right if I'm if I'm running things I'm
like he can make every movie he can
possibly make while I'm here at the
studio and even if he wants to take
movies away from other people my [ __ ]
could come into my house and be like I'm
remaking clerks I'll go do it JJ go
ahead put the [ __ ] better put in call
her running and [ __ ] can you do lens
flare in black-and-white
he's a [ __ ] born entertainer yes with
movies same way too Spielberg was born
to like we'd [ __ ] make you have a
good time and [ __ ] like that
and it comes right out that's cool man
that's awesome reviews talking about the
force awakens is more like a Spielberg
film they felt it was very Raiders of
the Lost Ark I didn't get that at all
just that by virtue of the fact they won
a few places mmm
but other than that Star Wars there is a
bit of a breathlessness to it and in the
same way that look Lawrence Kasdan
co-wrote it with him yeah and it's got
that pace it's got that drive like
there's I watch Star Wars again and
there's a bit of time in the desert
where you're like all right it's very
languorous that way yeah and so Caspar
saws like [ __ ] to see the shark it's
not so much it's a lot of like they were
karate chopping the fences again but she
ain't the shark no no but so yeah like
there's there's definitely like a sprint
happening even when they get to the how
do we blow up the Starkiller base we're
just gonna [ __ ] go in there yeah like
we could explain what gives us I did
like a graphic of like this was the
Death Star this is your brain on drugs
yeah any questions I'll shoot that thing
up
I understand excuse me I got fun we're
both you coming off coming I'm on the
upswing I'm on my way to the cold I I'll
watch him blow up a Death Star every
Star Wars movie if you give me the shot
which I still think about gives me
[ __ ] chills dude and again some
people feel like they blew up [ __ ]
Alderaan you dick but they didn't show
us this moment a moment where whatever
planet they were shooting down where the
public was and the show bunch of people
looking at fire and they can't do
anything that captured my imagination
man that's good filming because I was
like whoa immediately I put myself on
that planet of going what would I do I
just start jerking off it's just what
there's nowhere to run see now and now I
want to see you make the day before
Starkiller base movie you I can I've
just like so what I love you so much I
want to marry you Oh God let's get
married tomorrow at 9:00 all right this
would be great
wait are you throwing rice at us yes
flame that I like that very much I
thought that was badass like blowing up
five planets like you were taking a
[ __ ] McHugh ball shot it was like
that was cool but the notion that
they're a bunch of people looking up
going like what why what is this whoa oh
and you cam ranh that's [ __ ] up that's
yeah damn that's a crimson ocean movie
had some darkness to it man little bit
opens up with like kill everyone in the
village of spoilers gillip yes by the
way if you got this far yeah come on but
funerals but heavens man the idea of
brutality of the first orders not
implied no no not so much
genocide um all right so I love those
who got revolution I love those two
movies yes
nobody has but I love those two moves go
see force awakens and go see read don't
really think your dad to go see Creed
yeah if you can't you tell you man it's
just the last scene Creed like destroyed
you struck me and I realized why I was
watching it they walk that you know
spoilers man
they finally go up the rocky steps but
rocky goes up the steps
take an old mangoes and the steps being
helped yeah by Michael B Jordan and I
was a child of 70s I saw the movie with
my father so number one you're like all
the pathos of older rocky kind of
getting up those two and then instantly
I'm like that was my dad before he died
he didn't look as good as Rocky
mmm-ma that much right now but like
moving slow and [ __ ] so instantly
waterworks would turn on and he gets up
to the top and he at that moment where
he's just like I used to believe like
you know I could see my whole life from
up here oh he better get a [ __ ] if he
doesn't win an Oscar it's because he's
got a win an Oscar unless he does
something horrible he's got to like run
into a bus full of nuns in order for
this not to happen he's gorgeous be like
you know because he's got it's weird cuz
he's played the character bunch yeah for
40 years but this is the first time
maybe since like Rocky 3 that I give a
[ __ ] good I'm like not just because I've
seen them all I'll get me wrong I'm
invested like it's a TV show
I'm there until they cancel this program
and that performance transcends every
other performance ad I mean it's
material yeah so strong koogler and
again kids him and his buddy were in
school gone wouldn't be fun to write a
rocky movie with no connections
whatsoever one came up with a rocky
movie it exists now dream big kids
that's crazy everything is possible
everything is possible
well alright that's all we got man
that's it dude let's jump out of here
that's it for this edition we're gonna
come back next week and go over to Comic
Book II stuff and what about DC and
Marvel and and then after that it'll be
our final show of the year you're like
what guys just got started we're done
we're taking it easy
you take him to the Italian way we only
work like 12 weeks a month LCS to hear
something like in any event thanks for
hanging out man
I bet Kevin Smith mark barnard come back
to this to the fact cave for more fat
man I'm Batman next week same fat time
same fat channel right here
www.youtube.com / Kevin Smith I think I
remembered can get this
you